hey everybody Here I am we have
officially closed the phase during which
I had the crazy hair because I got a
haircut it's all done on the bonus show
today I actually told the story of the
full experience but it is gone and it is
back to somewhat normal me it feels
great it really does I have to tell you
it's just been it's been bad it's been
really really bad and I know that we
were having a good time with the spiking
and the man bun and the entire thing but
it had to end it had to end and it just
it feels great and it's been so hot here
in Massachusetts that it's just been a
really great thing we are here today
because Donald Trump's press secretary
Kayleigh Magon Annie will be holding a
press briefing either at the top of the
hour or like in an hour and I am very
interested to see if she will be asked
questions about the FDA withdrawing the
emergency use authorization on hydroxy
chloroquine as Donald Trump calls it and
we will see what else comes up her press
briefings lately have started
increasingly late
they have been increasingly short and
she has taken very few questions
sometimes as little as 90 seconds of
actual presentation because and actually
I appreciate that because when they get
to talk it's all lies I'd rather just go
right to the questions so welcome we are
back again it's been quite a weekend I
at a cafe this weekend if you can
imagine something so crazy completely
isolated nobody around me and I had an
iced coffee isn't that just completely
crazy in the era of coronavirus there's
a picture of that in fact on my
Instagram page but we will get to that
Jimmy big nuts sent in a super chat
where he says how many people tuned in
to show and streams just for the hair
who we can argue whether it's ninety
nine point two or ninety nine point four
percent yeah I feel like I'm gonna lose
99% of my audience because my hair is
normal again norm normal I mean you know
normal for me right I mean you know it's
it's all relative I can still do this
but
yeah I certainly maybe maybe losing some
some from the standpoint of audience
size we may experience a problem okay as
many of you know we still have
coronavirus here in the United States we
have just hit 118 thousand deaths
increasingly the problem states are yes
California continues to be a problem but
the early hotspots are on the decline
dramatically in terms of new cases
Illinois is down here New York is down
here we here in Massachusetts are all
the way down here which I'm really
really proud about but increasingly so
other than the early hotspot of
California it's Florida North Carolina
Texas in Arizona these are the four new
hotspots Alabama Tennessee Georgia South
Carolina so understand that the early
hot spots were hotspots because of high
population density and many flights to
the source areas China and Europe the
second wave of hotspots are hotspots
because they have terrible policy
Florida North Carolina Texas Arizona
Alabama Tennessee Georgia South Carolina
these were early hotspots Virginia
Arkansas Maryland was an early hotspot
so we're now seeing this sort of
two-tiered situation taking place and it
is really really bad a couple other
things to play for you Donald Trump is
having a lot of trouble with black
voters 8% of black voters support him
they thought it would be a good idea to
have him interviewed by Fox News black
anchor Harris Falkner not the ubiquitous
white blond and it went really really
bad let's just look at a couple of clips
it's just in general I mean the economy
is the great unifier I think I've done
more for the black community than any
other president and let's take a pass on
Abraham Lincoln because he did good
although it's always questionable you
know in other words the end result we
are free mr. president but we don't
they're pretty well you understand
I'm gonna take a pass he doesn't get
Honest Abe as we call you say you do so
really really we were just it went bad
really quickly here's Trump talking
about how chokeholds are so innocent and
perfect yeah
and I think the concept of choke all
sounds so innocent so perfect and then
perfect guys if it's a one-on-one now if
it's two-on-one that's a little bit of a
different story depending depending on
the toughness and strength you know
we're talking about toughness and
strength we're talking there's a
physical thing here also of course but
if a police officer is in a bad scuffle
and he's got somebody that's really
interesting so this is like mega cringe
here's Trump arguing protesters didn't
even really know why they were there
when he called out mom on that tape it's
a heart punch so I'm curious from you
what do you think the protesters not not
the looters and the riders we're
intelligent enough to know the
difference in our country right what do
you think they want what do you think
they need right now from you renegade
protesters for different reasons and
then you had protesting also because you
know they just didn't know I've watched
so the Trump is asked why are people
protesting his first thing is some
protesters didn't know why they were
there watch you very closely why are you
here and they really weren't able to say
but they were there a reason perhaps but
a lot of them really were there because
they following the crowd a lot of them
they were there because what we
witnessed was a terrible thing right
what we saw was a terrible thing and
we've seen it over the years we haven't
you know this was one horrible example
but you've seen other terrible examples
you know that what on earth is he
talking about here is this is this is
about when the looting starts starts the
shooting star nut starts when the
looting starts the shooting starts me
and and I'm Paris on TV but I'm a black
woman I'm a mom
and you know when and you've talked
about it but we haven't seen you come
out and be that consoler in this
instance and the tweets when the looting
starts the shooting starts off why those
words so that's an expression I've heard
over the years and it didn't work - I
think Philadelphia the mayor of
Philadelphia
good morning he comes from 1967 I was
about 18 months old at the time
everybody's shooting wiki cuz they
probably got it wrong but it was from
the chief of police in Miami he was
cracking down and he meant what he said
and he said I don't even care if it
makes it look like root allottee I'm
gonna drive down when the looting starts
the shooting starts right that
frightened a lot of people when you you
told it also comes from a very tough
mayor who I might have been police
commissioner at the time but I think
mayor of Philadelphia named Frank Rizzo
so Frank Rizzo never actually said it
but he was in favor of brutal repression
of protestors that they had that in
common and he had an expression like
that but I've heard it many times from I
think it's been used many times very
strong it means two things
well one is if there's looting there's
probably going to be shooting and that's
not as a threat that's really just a
fact because that's what happens and the
other is if there's looting there's
going to be shooting this is very
they're very different meanings
interesting very very interesting mr.
president so the idea of course was put
Trump to be interviewed by a black
anchor woman and it did not go well at
all like really really bad let me see if
I have anything else from it okay I'm
not gonna play this when Trump you know
defaulted to talking about these were
riots but really they were protests and
there were some people who were looting
and I already played this one for you
guys so yeah very very ugly I'll get to
the West Point stuff momentarily we are
standing by for Caylee Mackin Annie at
the top of the hour welcome to everybody
just joining us I so appreciate that
you're here with me
I see people happy sad about my haircut
I think I definitely do look younger
with this haircut I'm so this is a three
year beard it took me three
years to grow this so I definitely don't
want to get rid of that but the hair is
gone my friends the hair is gone I do
want to say a quick thank you to
benjamin piddle benjamin piddle is new
member number one today at join
pakman.com and i really really
appreciate your support I also will say
thank you to Catherine who just made a
pledge on patreon or petraea on as I
once heard it called a patreon.com slash
david pakman show you are number two
today cuz it's all counting very much
appreciate that
super chats continue to come in as we
stand by for Kaylee Mac and Annie Oh
people saying I should also shave my
arms yeah I don't think we're gonna be
doing that anytime soon appreciate folks
subscribing via twitch prime always
appreciated nasty questions quoting
terrace Falkner but we are free lol John
Kurokawa says can you remember any
administration that has consistently
started their press briefing so late
thanks for projecting your hair very
strongly I don't remember any
administration starting so late
javi Rodriguez says do you anticipate a
second kovat lockdown listen I have a
big story on today's the big broadcast
show that we may not have a second wave
in the sense that the first wave may
never end and the numbers are looking
really really bad in fact let's pull up
the overall case numbers here as you can
see this is it's barely a decline right
like it's we've been almost in a plateau
now for almost two and a half months and
it is very ugly now the deaths
fortunately have come down but there are
real questions as to whether these
deaths are being hidden we know some
states were hiding cause of deaths I
don't know if we can even trust it I
don't even know if we can trust I don't
know what we can trust at this point in
time Danny Thompson says this boomer
thanks you for keeping the facial hair
looks great and unlike the shaven face
makes you look your age in the best way
Wow hello now you need to re-record your
pre-pandemic promos to match your new
look very much so
Walker Anderson says you seem quick to
highlight negative headlines on Texas
and Florida is your position that these
states should be shut down on what
statistical basis
my position is these
they should not have been that these
states did the wrong thing from the
beginning I don't live in these states
fortunately and I'm not dictating public
policy what I'm telling you is they've
they're exploding when you look at by
the way I don't know if people have seen
this but this almost seems fake Florida
coronavirus cases let me show you this
like it almost looks fake because it's
so crazy I mean like just like look at
this this is completely bonkers so I
don't know what they should do I know
what they should have done they actually
should have locked down early if the
entire country had done it we might be
dealing with things like you know Taiwan
or Switzerland or all of these other
places Greece that dealt with it well we
didn't we failed baby photo says do you
think Trump could successfully blame
black lives matter protests for kovat
case spikes could he gain traction from
it maghen and he brought it up last week
yeah he's gonna try and it could work I
mean his followers are not the brightest
so it very well could work kids books by
david says Tucker Carlson just Tucker
Carlson AC says can't wait to watch the
chest stream oh yeah so listen tomorrow
night we are having the second chess
tournament the david pakman show chess
tournament okay you can sign up for it
right now at david pakman.com slash
chess we have 17 people signed up this
is totally free it's just a community
event
I'm not we're not trying to make money
from this it's for everybody it's just
fun because things are so bad right now
david pakman.com slash chess we had 500
players last time a look at people
signing up 19 now we had 500 players
last time I want to beat that I would
love to have a thousand people play in
this tomorrow night if you don't want to
play but you want to watch I will stream
myself playing okay so you can just
watch me if you want to play and you
don't want to watch me okay we could
talk later
but that's also okay you could just play
and if you want to do both you can play
in the tournament while watching me play
and it's it's gonna be great starts at
8:00 p.m. Eastern tomorrow night thirty
hours away as it says right here on Lee
chess org if you
direct link to the tournament david
pakman.com slash chess and we've got two
people rated over two thousand already
playing which is absolutely great but we
also have folks with low ratings which
is absolutely and completely fine it's
open to everybody and you'll be matched
against people roughly of your skill
level so there's no reason at all not to
play it's gonna be a great from the
standpoint of community we will have
elements of gaming we will have elements
of streaming it's just gonna be amazing
I may even I may even have whiskey
during the event so david pakman.com
slash chess 34 people now signed up to
play and it's gonna be really great
so do it do it do it it's gonna be
tremendous i want to say thank you to
Laura Driscoll who is new member number
three today at join pakman.com always
appreciate everybody named Laura who
gets memberships it's just a good name
it's just a concise great name other
super chats that are coming in let's see
Matias Germany says David you look
younger than ever very strongly yeah a
lot of people said I look very much
younger with my haircut which is fine
Arun Mehta says could you see Trump
kicking the UN out of New York City no I
don't think so
Walker Anderson says you are saying they
should have shut down earlier but
showing stories that condemn a reopening
not convinced by the unintended
consequences of shutdown Walker I have
to tell you I'm bored with you I find
your comments boring every we you know
there's a very anybody who's been paying
attention understands what certain
states did wrong and what certain states
did right everybody in the science and
medical community has been trying to do
you know that the best they can from day
one and it's it's very clear that things
are going very very bad in some of these
red states that are just spiking that
they're not even at they're not even at
the waveone peak yet you know we were
supposed to be in an in-between period
between waves one and two these
disastrous states haven't even peaked
wave one um let's see auntie picker
rainin says in Finland we have an
excellent police and I find abolish the
police movement in the u.s. Cillian
counterintuitive policing can be fair
and just yeah that's my view
alch says at least some news from
Supreme Court today big story coming up
on that tomorrow pair Terrence says New
Zealand are free from the chains of
kovat one country done now shape up all
other countries yeah New Zealand what's
New Zealand has been able to do has been
tremendous really really amazing let me
just get these clips played for you
because I have I did prepare them over
the weekend Donald Trump very gingerly
descending this ramp and normally
officers would walk behind Trump it
seems this officer was told stay with
him and as you can see Trump struggling
favoring his left side some suggesting
Trump has a right side issue he
struggled to lift the glass with his
right hand did he have a stroke that was
what explained being rushed to Walter
Reed those last two steps Trump took he
referred to in a tweet as running down
the last ten feet that so that's what
Trump I don't I know that you probably
didn't see it but Trump calls this
running ten feet Trump just ran ten feet
if you didn't know that if you don't
care about reality Trump just ran ten
feet also here is Trump struggling with
the glass of water to kind of help
myself with his deadpan I have no
interest in making fun of medical issues
we know that if this were Hillary it
would be Hillary's Parkinson's all over
again if this were Biden it would be
Biden must resign immediately and end
his campaign because he is unfit but for
whatever reason with Donald Trump this
is all considered totally normal
very unusual way it's like he brought
the glass let me see if I can mimic this
he brings the glass up eighty percent he
tries to go down the last twenty percent
but he can't like he only goes down 20
percent but ten percent so you've got
ten to bridge so he this is the motion
so you've got eighty ten pun that's the
that's essentially it right there and a
very very unusual way of drinking water
if I've ever seen one so very just it's
all wheat listen I don't know what's
going on but clearly something is going
on and if it were a Democrat they would
be saying cancel cancel cancel cans
thank you - oh this is so weird people
are signing up for twitch subscriptions
but it's not showing me in the Activity
Feed who they are that is horrible I see
the number going up but it's not
actually telling me who they are isn't
that horrible oh okay
LD Ayin is one of the new twitch prime
subscribers
oh wow I've got to like scroll through
this is bad there's some kind of glitch
there's a some kind of glitching kimchee
for example I see in the chat has
subscribed with twitch Prime interesting
alright well hopefully twitch can get
that taken care of
I do plan I know people told me tomorrow
night for the chess tournament let's see
by the way how many people are now
signed up 46 beautiful 46 people now
signed up for the chess tournament
tomorrow night I will be doing H
strictly speaking chess stream on Twitch
I will actually set the topic to chess I
know that people have been telling me in
advance David you've got to do that very
powerfully promotes your your twitch
stream so I will be doing that if you
want to play find the tournament you can
just join it right now
it starts in 30 hours but you can join
now at david pakman.com slash chess and
our top rated player we have two over
2000 rated players right now which we
love and we also have people rated under
a thousand under 1100 everybody's
welcome
you'll be matched with people of your
own skill level so there's no reason not
to play it's it's free open to all skill
levels I am not that great I mean I'm
sort of in the bottom half certainly
from the standpoint of skill so it's
going to be fun it's gonna be really
really fun I think you guys are going to
enjoy it oh and uh Steven Kenneth
destiny bonel ii said he would be
streaming it as well which would be
great I think that would bring a lot of
attention to the to the tournament if
that indeed happens let me say thank you
to mean why I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly who is new member number four
join pakman.com dennis liquori air is
new member number 5 and Danny Thompson
just pledged on patreon and we are going
to count that as number 6 why not it all
counts everything counts today that's
the beautiful thing other super chats
coming in Walker Anderson sorry to bore
you echo chambers are great alright
jazzy it's just all of this stuff has
been debunked already so it's like it's
just boring for my audience to have to
hear me talk about the same stuff over
and over again jazzy jeff real talk says
hillary lost to trump bat in south
carolina in SC ken claybournes
claybournes biden endorsement make biden
a serious contender in south carolina in
2020 I don't believe Biden will win so I
don't believe Biden has a shot at
winning South Carolina but it might be
close enough that Trump has to spend
some money there which would be great
Jacob Ratner says you think defund the
police will excite the Republican base
it might and that's why I don't believe
that that's uh that's that's what we
want to be hearing and I've already put
out a bunch of stories about that David
gora says Trump's behavior can be
explained by his tight tie being on too
tight John McKinney says if Donald Trump
loses will he blame third party
candidates I doubt it no says if
Costco's are packed why can't small
stores open I I don't know what state
you're referring to but small stores in
Massachusetts have opened and you need
you gotta wear a mask to go in those are
the rules I do always look at twitch
chat you know everybody like I see that
there are people sowing fear uncertainty
and doubt on twitch by making people
think I ignore the twitch community I'm
not ignoring the twitch community
I love the twitch community people love
to tell others that I never look at the
twitch chat to prevent people from
subscribing it's like it's such a lame
technique my detractors show up and they
go David no you use ignoring us David
never looks at the twitch chat he's
ignoring us he never looks and then I
look and I just read stuff from the
twitch chat it's just to convince people
not to support me on twitch it's very
very lame and we don't come on guys it's
it's like
you know Walker Anderson always asking
me the same questions and boring you
guys it's boring love you guys too I see
everybody I'm noticing everybody I'm
noticing everybody don't worry we love
it and I'm seeing all I'm seeing the the
subscriptions sometimes I can't always
keep up with it all but I am seeing
everybody we appreciate absolutely every
single one of you thank you okay we are
hopefully just minutes from the start of
this White House press briefing with
Kaylee McKenna and Anna II and she will
be showing up no doubt late and not
talking too long but then taking some
questions yes I am aware I see people
asking me I am aware that the FDA has
pulled they've pinched off that just cut
it right off the emergency authorization
for hydroxy chloroquine it was not a
good idea and it's now been pulled I
don't know if she will be asked about
that I will remind folks that the number
one way the number one way to support
this channel stream twitch facebook
youtube the best way is you grab a
membership on my website join pakman.com
and boyd just signed up and she is new
member number seven and you can grab a
membership it takes under a minute it
really we joke around a lot about this
stuff but our primary source of funding
the one that you know all these other
sources of funding go like this
twitch youtube it's like a really bad
EKG it's like you know texas coronavirus
case numbers but membership is sort of
like what balances things out and just
hopefully slowly over time builds and
it's not a lot of money the coupon code
2020 now saves 66 percent so it's 2
bucks a month and if you pay for the
year it's only a dollar eighty a dollar
eighty on zero carry the five six over
three sine cosine divided by pi i think
it's like a dollar eighty three a month
if you pay for the entire year and i
will also sing your praises on stream so
i do appreciate
folks who are doing that also thanks to
you hot sacks who has subscribed over on
Twitch we love that as well other super
chats are coming in Dennis says would we
get our message across better if we said
demilitarized instead of defund the
police I believe so but a lot of people
are mad at me for saying that so that's
my view
Dennis Dylan Johnston says have you ever
thought of picking up shogi like
Japanese chess I have not I have not but
uh I trust tomorrow we are now over
fifty players in tomorrow's David Pakman
show chess tournament you can sign up
free at david pakman.com slash chess and
it will be tomorrow night at 8 p.m.
Eastern I will be streaming it'll be a
nice community event an evening stream
we will have hype trains like the one we
have going on right now we're gonna have
everything so please do participate I
believe the exact number last time for
the first tournament was about 510
players so I would love to have a
thousand people play tomorrow but even
if we don't get to that I think it'll
still be a great tournament and it is
david pakman.com slash chess 55 folks
currently signed up still just to raided
over two thousand last time
International Master Eric Rosen also my
chess teacher won the tournament but we
had lots of lower rated folks and we
love everybody you know Trump says he
loves the undereducated and he loves the
highly-educated but it's like [ __ ] I
want everybody to play doesn't matter
your rating make an account it's free
and we're gonna have a great time
tomorrow so very very exciting stuff ok
other super chats while Walker at ease
says put in a good word with Rogen to
get destiny on I am NOT I don't know
that I'll be talking to Rogen anytime
soon Danny Thompson says third
membership time is the charm I am a
website member and a YouTube member and
now a patron perfect trifecta
thanks Danny Danny caught I believe
Danny called in when I took live calls
the other day 1:21 click bezel says just
signed up for chess good luck thank you
I don't expect to win but I consider it
an honor merely to participate merely to
participate thanks to Joseph Montgomery
who is new member number eight today at
joined pakman.com thanks Joseph very
much appreciate that also want to say
thanks to Liam Bowie or bow II to quote
Avril Lavigne Liam Bowie is the way I
would say it that's how I've typically
heard it said Ben Huffman has sent a
super chat kwb says looking sharp David
did you get a haircut I did I got a
haircut I described the entire
experience on today's bonus show but in
short it felt very safe during the
shampooing element of the haircut I was
there was a row of five shampooing
stations all had plastic curtains
between them and nobody was sitting in
any of the others and during the haircut
itself I think there were five salon
chairs between me and the next person
getting their hair cut so it was just my
hairdresser and me other than just
getting really hot because I had my mask
on and you know the plastic smock I
guess that they put on you or whatever
it's called it felt totally safe and it
was you know at a certain point to get
my sideburns - you know trim me up as
you all know around the year I had to
pull my mask sort of to the side and
hold it then flipped to the other side
and it was relatively uneventful and
I've got a haircut and I'm good now I
should be good for a couple of months at
least I went like four months without a
haircut and I think it's fine it was
good to do thanks to Dennis for grabbing
a soy boy level membership over on
YouTube very much appreciate that people
asking on Twitch when this starts it
starts 13 minutes ago so Kaylee McKenna
nee is running late as usual
and the room is mostly full so I
wouldn't be surprised to see her start
relatively soon but she seems to like to
build the anticipation I guess as the as
the case maybe people asking if there's
prizes for the chess tournament no I
mean you know it there's not really it's
just you you just win that the prize is
winning but it really it's participation
that is that is the big thing the way it
usually works is you know some of these
really high rent ranked players are the
ones that tend to win because they win
the most games the most quickly but
because people are matched we have
enough people who play where you'll
mostly be matched against people that
are roughly your skill level so yeah
it's it's doesn't you don't have to be
good just as long as you know how the
pieces move I say show up and play it's
gonna be a really really great thing
maybe maybe I will offer a lock of my
hair to the winner that would be an
interesting prize to offer yeah maybe
okay
Christian Jensen has signed up at the
beta level on YouTube Flor says many
conservatives cheer actual authoritarian
government governance or government and
after everything they've seen so far how
can those on the Left seriously support
gun control that's it that's a more
complicated issue it's easy to come up
with like a hot take but that that's
there's actually a lot more to that but
I have left-wing friends who are in the
process of getting guns because they are
indeed thinking listen if things get
ugly with the virus if things get ugly
in the fall if Trump loses barely and
says it was rigged it we don't want then
having all the guns right so I have some
some liberal friends who are believing
something very similar to what it sounds
like you're pointing to you here
Alexander the Snivy says sleep
deprivation might possibly be making
Donald's declining mental health even
worse yeah he's claimed that he sleeps
for hours a night for like the last 30
years that's not particularly healthy
and
so that that certainly could be a factor
I wouldn't be certainly wouldn't
wouldn't come as a surprise to me let me
see if I had any other things here oh
there was one of these so here's Trump
referring to the former president
ulysses s grant as you lysias and we
lead we need you to carry on the spirit
of the great general
Alyssia cess grant ulysses s grant there
you go and then was there anything else
we already did the water clip we did the
ramp clip I showed this to you already
yeah we I have a so I actually have a
whole segment publishing at I think it's
5:30 p.m. Eastern Time on this so I
don't want to spend too much time on it
because I I'm doing an entire segment on
it which I think you'll like I think
you'll like very very much okay I do
want to say thank you to Uncle slumps
uncle slumps is new member number ten
today at join pakman.com we have what I
consider to be a pretty modest target of
25 website memberships and I had a I had
a conversation today via email with a
viewer who wrote me and said listen you
know I feel bad I want to so I've been
watching you for so long I want to
support the work you do but I really
can't afford it I don't I don't want the
money of anybody who's in that position
right this is progressive independent
media the point is it should be
available to everybody what brought my
sharpie should be available to everybody
replacement though regardless of ability
to pay
we estimate only one-half of one percent
of our audience is subscribed in any
kind of financial way and that's fine
right it's the folks who have a dollar
or two that they can put towards
something that they want to support
that's who we're targeting and I'm glad
to do this show for the 99.5 percent who
never pay anything it's fine that's the
whole point is to get the information
out get the analysis out etc if you are
in a position where a dollar or two a
month is okay those are the folks that
we want to see grab memberships at join
pakman.com 10 have done it today I would
love to get to
five and of course the coupon code in
blue text saves you sixty-six percent I
did see the Supreme Court ruling today
on LGBT discrimination at work I have
already drafted a big reaction piece for
the show tomorrow and that will be
coming up tomorrow we didn't get to it
today but we will have that tomorrow I
think it's gonna be very powerful David
Adams says via super chat what's your
thoughts on the Capitol Hill autonomous
zone in Seattle I don't know what chop
is Capitol Hill
what is opie Capitol Hill something
police chas I know is Capitol Hill
autonomous zone
I am against stuff like that
I come from Argentina where you know
when you see what happens when police
abandon or when there are police no-go
zones it's not good and so I am I am NOT
for it but I also want to make sure that
the Chas is not being incorrectly
reported as disproportionately violent
or anything like that it's mostly
peaceful people painting murals etc etc
thanks to Elizabeth a for signing up at
the beta level on YouTube Robert Mifflin
says do you think Kamala is still the VP
favorite thoughts on rice
I do believe Kamala is still the
favorite I'm not saying I want common
law to be the VP nominee I'm saying I do
believe that she is the favorite if you
force my hand that's who I would guess
is the most likely as of right now let
me say thank you to Michael Robbins who
has made a pledge on patreon and his
supporter number 11 today thanks Michael
also thanks to Aris deeds Baez Aris
deeds buys is number 12 today at join
pakman.com very much appreciated also
the great Patrick Darnell has signed up
and his new member number 13 thanks
Patrick very much appreciate it yes I am
from Argentina
I see people confused about that I was
born in Argentina came to the US
when I was five we are standing by for
Caylee McKenna nee expected to start
nineteen minutes ago she was very late
the last time I covered one of her press
briefings I think about 4550 minutes
late only spoke for like 90 seconds and
then took some questions we will see how
today goes usually this door closes
before she dramatically walks out of it
but we're keeping an eye on the entire
thing with multiple sources multiple
multiple sources if you're just joining
us tomorrow night I'm very excited about
this the second ever David Pakman show
chess tournament will be played on Lee
chess org you can sign up right now it's
free I'm selling you nothing it's just
an opportunity to do something at david
pakman.com slash chess last time
500 people played we have 67 people
currently set up to play tomorrow night
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time
Stephen Kenneth destiny bunnell ii told
me he would be playing in my tournament
as well so i'm hoping for a good turnout
and david pakman.com slash chess will
redirect you to this tournament there
will be a green button right here that
will say join mine says withdraw because
I've already joined I can't withdraw I'm
not gonna withdraw from my own
tournament that would be really
embarrassing and really really looking
forward to it as you can see ratings
anywhere from 965 all the way up to 2032
it would be amazing so by the way he I
actually want to request the help of the
twitch chess community if any of the
people in my twitch stream or YouTube or
anywhere if any of you are in touch with
or are part of any chess communities any
of the people you know that I watch
whether it's Hikaru Eric Rosen Alexandre
botas or been fine go you know any of
any big streamers if you can get them to
play in my
tournament tomorrow night and stream it
it would be amazing we could end up with
5,000 people in this tournament to be
perfectly frank if any of you guys who
are overlapping with the chess community
and that it would just be absolutely
tremendous could pokey main may be
playing my chess tournament can you
imagine and again people are saying
they'll just win it doesn't matter
people get matched up against players of
equivalent skill so the grandmasters
will play against the grandmasters and
that's great and then you know all of us
schlubs will play against each other and
it's it's going to be great so that's we
have 30 hours to make this happen
help me pull in some notable chess
streamers to my chess tournament 8:00
p.m. Eastern david pakman.com slash
chess that's the that's the way to do it
okay
your boy blue says capitol hill occupied
protest okay that's what Chop stands for
got it thanks to McCoy pool for signing
up on YouTube music miscellaneous says
thoughts on Sam Harris's lated latest
podcast haven't listened to it haven't
listened to him Arthur should see has
also sent a super chat which I very much
appreciate it so people are confused
about the chess link a minute I'm gonna
tell it to you right now okay are you
ready david pakman.com slash chess david
pakman.com slash chess it will redirect
you to this page and then you can have
the actual li chess link yes please
indeed invite hikaru that would be
amazing
invite uh you know invite everybody that
you want it's open to all okay let me
say a few other member thank-yous as i
don't want to miss anybody
big thanks to Jesse lamb who is new
member number 14 today
Trevor McWaters is new member number 15
thanks Trevor
Julio says Soriano is new member number
16 today Thank You Julio Curtis dries is
new member number
Nathan pop is new member number 18
what's the name of a word that sounds
like what it describes what's that word
because pop I think is one of those
write like bark would count if you
actually think that a dog's bark sounds
like bark what is the name of that
somebody tell me onomatopoeia
that's exactly right yes very good thank
you okay well in any case we have one
nathan pop thanks to Stephanie Meyers
who is number 19 I appreciate that
Eric gothner I believe that's the right
pronunciation is new member number 20
also big thank you to Katie besito Katie
Posse doe is new member number 21 today
we see Fox News's John Roberts here
delivering a some kind of speech to Fox
News and it looks like we have a
photographer coming out and we should be
just minutes minutes minutes minutes
from the start of this press briefing a
lot of continued it's weird people seem
really confused about the chess
tournament it seems so simple like it's
just tomorrow night at 8:00 you just
make an account and you play I don't
know why it's so confusing it's just
it's just chess you know yeah I can't
teach you the rules you have to know how
to play up to 83 people registered for
tomorrow night's tournament love it love
it love it love it and in all
seriousness I see people in twitch chat
saying you're gonna reach out to this
grand master that Grand Master whatever
if anybody gives you a response that
they plan to play and ever you know
they'll all be streaming their evening
streams please do email me because I
would love to know in advance if there
are going to be some major players
playing then I would love to know about
that no no I did get a haircut no plans
in terms of the beard right now I
probably will do a little bit of a trim
but no no big plan to get rid of it it
is 8 p.m. Eastern tomorrow I want to say
thank you to quake Z 7890 who has now
subscribed with twitch
for ten months in a row ten months in a
row I think I only have a few people who
are in the 10-month category from the
standpoint of time and I really very
very much appreciate that so people on
Twitch having trouble with the link to
chess people on YouTube struggling with
super chats
it's just the dollar sign it's the
dollar sign that is either overlaid on
the chat window or at the bottom of the
chat window if you're on a desktop if
you need to contact me by email as
people they're asking use the contact
form on my website use my contact form
on my website and that will get it'll be
routed oh we had this is so funny we had
to put in I I wasn't necessarily gonna
call attention to this but it is kind of
funny if we have time here we get so
many of the same enquiries via email
that we added like all of these
disclaimers before the contact form
because it's there's just so much stuff
and we added an FAQ and on the FAQ this
one is a really funny one that my web
developer was like do you really need
that I wrote to David on the website
Twitter YouTube Facebook and didn't hear
back what gives I'm not able to right
everybody back individually I'm upset
displeased angry with an advertisement
that showed up before after or during
one of your videos on YouTube Facebook
or twitch we have no control over which
ads show up on our content on those
platforms and you should contact them
directly to express their displeasure we
get a lot of emails about that where
someone says an epoch times ad showed up
before your video I'm disgusted with
that I have no control over it we have
no control over that so we're trying to
reduce the amount of the number of these
inquiries that come in on that basis
your boy blue says would you get mutton
chops if Trump loses 2020 re-election
yes so I've gotten a bunch of questions
about this would I like shave into a
Hitler mustache if Trump loses like no
that's idiotic well that would be I'd be
ridiculed every time I leave the
and I want Trump like that's I'm winning
a bet if Trump blue that's Naik I want
Trump to lose why would I do something
horrible and stupid
if Trump loses which I want to see
happen
I am potentially willing to do something
something you know I would if there was
enough if we did some kind of membership
drive with some kooky number I would
potentially like bleach my hair or you
know I'm up for doing something I'm up
for mixing it up and doing funny things
oh what's going on is everybody leaving
it looks like everybody's getting up
what on earth is going on has this been
canceled
what the heck does anybody know for sure
if it's been canceled everybody's just
bailing what the hell it's a rush to get
out can we hear like a smoke alarm nope
no smoke alarm everybody just got up and
left at the exact same time if anybody
can point me to a tweet or something
that tells me what's going on I would
appreciate that nobody knows what on
earth I've never seen everybody just get
up and leave
are they relocating to the Rose Garden
or something this is bizarre what the
hell they're even taking the microphones
with them this is very unusual the White
House stream never even went live yeah
nobody's social distancing that's for
sure I don't know what just happened
let's check the official schedule and
see what's going on this would be a new
oh they're doing temperature checks look
everybody's getting temperature checked
as they go in oh you know what might be
going on so there was a 2:30 roundtable
scheduled here
what I think is going on this press
briefing was scheduled for two there was
a 2:30 Trump event scheduled a
roundtable propaganda event if people
are getting temperature checks
I'm guessing it's because they are being
moved that the press briefing was
cancelled and instead they're being
moved to the Trump event are we is that
so now they have to get their
temperature checks is that maybe what's
going on I have no idea this is bizarre
okay let's see if we go back to the
White House Channel let's see if they've
scheduled a different event they still
have the Magnani event and I'm not
seeing anything else here no if it's
just the Magon Annie with 6,800 people
watching 6300 everybody's just bailing
this is what a mess I mean just what an
absolute and total mess I see people
trying to send links but they don't seem
to be working this is crazy we I I mean
I apologize to any extent that I you
know participated in this fiasco but
let's see what they are doing if anybody
has any info let's see if Fox News has
set up a separate event now 16,000
people watching the empty room sometimes
the streams are at the bottom nothing
here wait now we've got a waiting for
event to begin let's refresh this one
all right I guess we'll just wait it out
briefly this is very very unprofessional
as people are pointing out just so wacky
this is crazy well listen while we wait
for things to be clarified let me just
make sure that I'm thanking everybody
who grabbed memberships I don't want to
miss everybody because I so appreciate
you guys Greymon mosque all is new
member number 22 alex Barty is new
member number 23 kathleen murphy is new
member number 24 and conner Mills is new
member number 25 you know what when we
get to 25 as I like to say let's go for
fifth
let's go for 50 we are so four people
just joining the press briefing seems to
have been canceled they just cancelled
it and instead when we look at the daily
schedule for Trump which I will pull up
right now so you had the 2:00 p.m. press
briefing scheduled it's already 2:30
president participates in a roundtable
on fighting for America's seniors it
seems as though they've just canceled
the press briefing altogether that this
is my best guess I don't have any other
idea as to what's going on delayed until
2:30 it is 2:30 that's that's the weird
thing and we don't know whether there's
going to be a different feed it's just
an absolute and total mess any other did
they sometimes the White House Channel
will create a new event but they have
not done that so far
I guess we'll give it a couple minutes
otherwise I might have to just bail I
mean like maybe this is it
maybe they're not we're not getting any
further today I don't know just a total
and complete mess
put up the White House camera ok I don't
know how to do that White House camera
let's say White House cam live um yeah
I'm not finding any White House camera
that would give us any information right
now White House the White House website
has this exact same thing going on they
moved it to oen yeah maybe that's what's
happening
bunker cam super chats continue to come
in briefing rescheduled until after the
roundtable okay you know what if that's
the case I don't want to cover Trump's
roundtable but if I don't get some work
done on tomorrow's show I'll just never
I'll never be ready I'll be working till
midnight so I'm gonna pinch off the
stream I don't want to cover Trump's
propaganda nonsense I'll be back for the
rescheduled press briefing okay
sorry for the false start guys I'll be
back remember in the meantime though
sign up for the chess tournament at
david pakman.com slash chess help me
recruit some grandmasters it's going to
be a great time tomorrow night I'll be
back when they come back